each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so this morning were delighted to
have Alexandra Cola from University of
California in Berkeley telling us about
merger techniques for community
optimization hi so I had a story to say
we'd say I'm gonna say thanks it's
relevant so four days ago I left my bag
in the car and my car got broken into
and my laptop got stolen and I lost all
my work which having backed up so I had
to redo my talk basically from a really
old version that I emailed my advisor
and the moral of the story is that you
should leave everything for the last day
because then everything can be done in a
day right so we'll see how it goes and
also back up always back up okay so um
that's me and I'm from Berkeley I'm
gonna be talking about two areas that
are very like heavily worked on in
theory and outside theory a special
graph theory semi-definite programming
and how these two areas are connected
basically in more ways than one so I'm
sorry question do they have a roller for
the slides or just with them that's fine
no ok so Specter graph theory is
basically studies the you know
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of graphs
and the relation between specter and
expansion introduced spectral techniques
as a very like popular tool for
applications in you know a lot of areas
for example image segmentation deals
with use of special techniques and
basically the use of spectral techniques
in revolutionizing what segmentation
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of random
walk matrices led to PageRank algorithm
and consent decree expanders have been a
very useful and popular tool in coding
and communication and you know
theory in general also
I invited methods and convex
optimization have been used long back as
far back as lovers that a function
bonding chromatic number of graph graph
partitioning graph labeling routing
networks and a lot of other and little
applications and now semi-definite
programming is basically the an
optimization the convex optimization
problem optimizes over the count of
positive semi-definite matrices and it
has been a major tool in in fields like
yeah automating control systems signal
processing communication networks
circuits statistics finance and a long
list and in theory in particular it has
been used heavily to create
approximation algorithm P hard problems
mostly and basically sometimes it works
great sometimes it doesn't and the study
of semi different problems in theory is
you here for mock Scott semi definite
program which I'm gonna get back to it's
very interesting by itself so we have
this two very popular areas and
basically if you look at them closer
then you see that they're connected in
more ways than one so in particular semi
definite programming the constraints of
semi definite programs take the form of
linear matrix inequality and they do
Sagat value bounds and on the other hand
most I can advise optimization problems
can be cast into an SDP so in my work
basically what I do is I try to merge
those two things to create approximation
algorithm or combinatorial optimization
problems and examine you know
limitations of SDP is when they cannot
create good approximation I'll go for
np-hard problems and all these
references to my work is what I'm going
to be talking about some more some less
but let's see an example of what I've
been talking about so far so what is
this duality between spectra and SDP the
mascot problem which everybody probably
knows it's fine the max cut in a graph
and it's a quadratic it's a maximization
problem
can be cast as a quadratic integer
integer programming formulation with you
know excise is plus one from one side of
the cut - one for the other side of the
cup so is that clear why that's the max
it's the waves on the edge so it's a
weighted maxcut problem and I'm just
giving a very intuitive slide of why
these two things can be connected I'm
not gonna talk about max cut at all
after that so yeah okay so however
integer programming you know it's a and
B hard so you cannot actually solve max
cut yeah and then the next best thing
or I mean maybe the next best thing is
an ST relaxation of max cut with Germans
who listen came up in 95 and you know
relax the condition that you know these
these things are vectors are not plus
minus 1 Y is you have an SDP relaxation
or mascot but let's see what happens if
we look at the door so we look at the
duel and it turns out that the door
gives an eigenvalue bound on the value
of max cap and actually this lambda
means that it's a do that basically
bound on the door
variable value and therefore by strong
duality the bound of the primal value
it's the most negative eigen value of
the graph that we're looking at so it
turns out that you start with an SDP
bias TP duality you come up with an
eigenvalue from these two things give
basically an idea of why this SDP and
spectra are very well connected so let's
see now
in particular in my work I'm interested
in expander graphs so in expander graphs
through a series and through their
spectra take their application you could
do that directly to right
oh sure no of course I'm just giving an
example of how I'm not gonna talk about
max cough you can do it directly you can
do it with STP I'm just giving an
example of how an eigenvalue of a graph
it's connected to an SDP of how through
duality you come up with why do you
start a spectrum and why would one thing
that mark Scott you know it would be
useful to look at spectra for example
and not something else making spectral
classes older than weaknesses ppm
that is very true of course the
connection of spectral systems
no I'm not but no but I mean in the in
the next second part of my talk I'm
gonna be showing a similar like STP
duality think that from an SDP gets an
eigenvalue and I want to indicate that
that's why I'm introducing it's your
mascot I would just thought it was a
simpler example to look at them I didn't
want to imply that that's you know their
only way to do this
if that is the point buy a very more
broad definition of duality so it's not
the only point it's one of the points I
actually gave a practice talk and
somebody asked me to give an example of
what I mean by duality that's why I have
this slide there so I'm sorry no maybe I
shouldn't have given a practice that but
anyway that happened after my laptop got
stolen so it's actually one of the
things that can be done in a day bear
with me okay so I'm particularly
interested in expander graphs and let's
look at why and what basically so in
computer science there are there like
major goals to create fault tolerant
networks fixed connectivity problems
speed up software testing cluster in
social networks and everything so what
did I do
so for example you have a network and
you're required that if like this
highway here fails then you have other
ways to go so that's a fault owner
network and for all those problems the
major component a common denominator
that you know actually facilitates the
solution of those problems is an
expander graph so that's the expander
not the girl
so yeah expander for graphs with Lars
conductions first mixing time and we'll
see more so its expansion well expand
the graph has largest expansion and the
capacity is just the ratio the you know
the minimum of the ratio of edges that
cross a cut over the number notes in the
sparse is to play their smallest side of
the cut and if you know a lot of
applications actually look for balanced
and sparse cuts like the ones I
mentioned before you might segmentation
divide and conquer heuristics and other
stuff so it could be great if we could
find a sparse card it would be amazing
but we can't because it's NP hard to
compute so the next best thing is to
find a reasonable approximation for that
and what does there is an approximation
for that well it's algebraic
connectivity just a quick review on a
graph laplacian is this
matrix it has the diagonal in the
diagonal the degree of its node minus
the adjacency matrix of the graph and
now the break connectivity is basically
the second smallest eigenvalue of a
laplacian and it's polynomial ty
computable so that's great but why would
I look at that
well there is triggers or a lot of
movement inequality I don't know how you
wanna in reference it but let's say
Tiggers inequality for now it gives a
reasonably good approximation of
expansion within a quadratic factor in
the worst case and you know also it
relates to mixing rate of markov chains
another nice properties of graph so
there you go it's a very good most of
the time a very good not most of the
time a lot of the times it's a very good
approximation for the sparse cut and
sometimes during this talk I'm gonna be
going back and forth lambda to have a
Laplace and lambda to have adjacency
matrix which are sort of related so if
you have any confusion about which
lambda I'm talking about just please ask
but I'm gonna try to be
I see parametric expansion ratio I'm not
saying that it's a you know always a
good approximation for the the ratio H
the one I define before I'm saying the
sparsity of Licata i defined here in the
previous
I am approximating the cut so if there
is a you know the lambda to gives a
bound of how big the cut can be so it's
not that you can find this parses cup
all with like by looking at eigenvalues
is not that you can say okay maybe from
quadratic factor apart it's in the worst
case it's really bad like it's not a
good tool but a lot of the cases when
it's not you know maybe these things are
closer together that's just a bound then
you can actually find what is the lower
bound of the sparse cut oh yeah yeah
yeah I'm just saying what is that graph
behaving like I mean in particular now
in particular the eigenvector cuts like
if you do spectrum of partitioning with
the eigenvectors then you can find
constant behave with that guarantee but
I am NOT I didn't say that if there are
no that's your question
you're the sign of that day I wake yeah
so you have you have address post
function and you may get basically find
it by reading
it's not necessarily class management
for the bishop but yeah I mean again
that's not my point I mean we're I'm
just trying to show why lambda 2 is
important okay so lambda 2 is important
great we all agree yeah okay and I'll be
talking about this um so I'm gonna give
you the how the talk is gonna be
structured I'm basically gonna look at
expanded graphs through semi-definite
programming and going back and forth it
to inspect your an expansion so the
first part I'm gonna be talking about
recent work on creating cost-effective
expanding networks we are local sparse
fires which I'm going to find second
part I'm gonna talk about the unique
games conjecture which is false on
expander constraint graphs and third
part which is this gonna be like a slide
with two of my papers that have done
explaining about lower bounds for SD
please if I have time but maybe not so
creating cost-effective expanding
networks with the use of local perspires
let's see what does that mean so
probably by the way this algorithm we
have a patent with Microsoft
we have a patent with Microsoft that's
how good I'll just say so the problems
of making a graph with a few good edges
so you're given parameter K and you're
asked to find K edges from a set of
candid edges do much maximize its
algebraic connectivity so we have this
graph and then optimal solution has this
orange as is there and say this gives
maximal to break connectivity in general
that's an np-hard problem and now
provable approximation algorithm is
known before our work there are a lot of
various things own but nothing with a
guarantee so a special case which I'm
gonna be talking now in this talk is
that if the graph actually could be
making to an expander with K edges then
find them so
I'm gonna give a constant approximation
algorithm for that problem how is it ii
love to serve the laplace so you want to
get you are a husband yes optimize
lenders over a plus and by adding edge
largest possibility inspector on gas yes
so yeah i mean you could see it either
way but so the point being that you know
I wanted to introduce algebraic
connectivity and see why I care about
this problem and not ads expansion like
why don't I look about edge expansion
and I look at the Brera connectivity and
that problem deals with that
optimization
quantity of the graph so you look
optimizing algebraic connectivity and in
particular if a graph like if this
optimal solution here was an expander
graph and you know we're guaranteed that
the graph couldn't wait to an expander
I'm gonna show you how to basically do
it with maybe 10 K edges not K edges but
you know so it's a by criteria and so
then just in case like one case not
written necessarily but around there
because if it was annamund you could put
an expander if it was constant you can
just brute force and find everything so
you know you need something in between
okay so um that's an eigenvalue
optimization problem as we said before
and it has an SDP relaxation so we have
an SDP we're at the STP but the optimum
with a weighted graph it could be the
complete weighted graph with tall weight
K instead of K exactly this I have total
weight K and you know I might be
unfortunate enough to have like the
complete graph and I don't know how to
pick K edges out of those so we need the
way to round the STP and find K edges so
now STP rounding has been like long back
a very crucial problem very important
problem that people worked on and you
know gehrman's williamson had the random
hyperplane rounding many other problems
use that then their view introduced a
new technique for rounding and actually
what we do we have a yet another new
technique for rounding which is called
local sparse variance for that
particular problem and what that does is
we find order of key edges and
approximate the best
love the - or algebraic connectivity
within some constant so well so we have
by criteria what my section so a quick
review for whoever doesn't know what the
graph sparse fire is just one slide
review we are asked to approximate any
graph C by a sparse graph H so we have
our graph G and we want like a sparse
graph aids with like weights and edges
that somehow approximate G and the
notion of approximation we use is
basically that these two quadratic forms
are very close to each other or that
basically eigen values are the same the
whole spectrum are the same oh sorry
yeah um that's but wenzer Karger with
cuts forest fires film on tanks we were
stava Spillman and buttons sorry yeah
I'm really bad at reading the references
so so basically we are asked to find a
graph that approximate for all practical
purposes the spectrum of G first our
breath of birds is true
if the spectrum is approximated within 1
plus or minus epsilon by this definition
so but I mean that doesn't make much
sense so far why would we look at that
well this is actually a generalization
of cats pacifiers for burns and Karger
paper like long back and if we relax
that requirement and ask that age
approximate the original graph only for
cut vectors just the for every cut the
weight that goes across the cat is
preserved
meaning that you know you you just we
restrict that requirement to zero one
characteristic vectors of the cut just
because this is the total weight of the
cut then you know you can see somehow
how this idea comes from and in fact the
last paper but some super stubborn
Spillman proved that every graph has a
specifier with a linear number of edges
or if you see deeper in what that says
it says whatever eigenspace I want to
approximate I can find the order of that
dimension number of edges to
approximated and for example I'm just
for ya example scaled constantly
expander which is not an expander here
but I just could not draw an expander
gives the sparse affair of the complete
graph so if you scale everything by an
over D then you have basically a whole
spectrum of complete graph is same
specter of scaled expander
because ok great so that's my own
already so because you need to preserve
the total number of ways you need to
scale every edge by an already so it
says that the irregular degree expander
so in order to complete graph as I
advise and our driven yeah yeah so in
particular you just need you know
instead of all the edges that cross the
cut to have the same way you just need
it all the way to be preserved so what
is a local specifier and what do we do
so as we said before we're looking for
an integral solution but the SDP could
be the complete weighted graph so that's
our SDP and if we could try to specify
Allah Batson superstar and Spillman I'm
gonna call it BSS from now because it's
too long to say
we could get up to order vanities which
is not good enough for K squared n well
this is really bad
exactly so that's really bad so we we
come up with the notion of local sparse
fires so by the way I'm again really
horrible I didn't mention that this is
joint work with Sanka angry my carrot
Savannah means a berry from when I was
in Microsoft Ning yeah I'm sorry about
that
so winter this a notion of local sparse
fires and the idea is to relax the
specification requirement and only ask
that the specifier is good at a specific
subspace so you know if we lack such
requirement for this axis in some
subspace of dimension K then by a
modification of the proof we get order
of linear number of edges in the
dimension of a subspace and find order
of cages that approximate my graph in
the sense that I want that is very good
and now we remember that the problem was
if the graph can be made the expander
then find the K edges so what subspace
do we look at though because you know
there are so many choices of K
dimensional subspace is there is unclear
what you should look at so if my
original graph plus the optimal number
of edges was an expander which means
that the lambda 2 of the resulting graph
was some constant and by looking at them
in maximum fragment values it says that
basically by adding edge is the best you
can do is lambda K in increasing order
you cannot do more and I mean in
particular if K was bigger than n we
would look at the rank of Phillip less
and you were adding of the laplacian of
the new edges and if you say that just
PS tip is a relaxation of there is no
problem then basically if you're strict
of the eigenspace of the first case
eigenvectors of laplacian OG you get a
good graph with constant algebraic
connectivity so the approximation that
we get depends on lambda K and lambda is
TP so if both of them were constant I
mean if one of them are constant then
we're good in particular if the graph
can be made and expanded one of them
would be constant however there is a
catch
works great for expanders but that's not
our general theorem which I'm not going
to present right now but I need to say
that what happens if lambda K or lambda
s appear horrible like one of her we
were that I don't know or one event well
then we have a more general theorem that
also has a different notion of
specification yeah exactly so what
happens if they're horrible so that yeah
okay
I already said that I should have said
I'm sorry so then we also we also have a
general theorem that actually specifies
for the whole subspace but observe the
following that we we already have G so G
is already a really bad sparse fire
maybe for G Plus optimum Rho G Plus STP
grass so maybe it's a really but specify
but at some directions it's gonna be
good like if you look at the largest I
gave them space then it's gonna be good
you don't need to do anything so by by
using that intuition and a lot of
technical work which I'm not going to
talk about we get the generalization of
that specification requirement with few
extra edges and that works well in a
bigger class of graphs and that's the
people I've worked with under which is
yeah oh yeah I mean it's um it works for
graphs that lambda case for example of
order K RN and we are currently working
on the whole spectrum but that's work in
progress so I don't wanna so that's the
first part of my talk if you have any
questions about that that's a good time
to ask if you general isn't what makes
is possible local
all of them is something I named it it's
a global sports fire basically so the
love this thing this worked the general
theorem it's not a local sparse fire
it's a global spar in the sense it
approximates every direction so before
like the previous slide when we
restricted to that subspace of first K
eigenvectors
I call it local because you look at the
restricted subspace
now the sparser fire is you basically
want to choose K edges out of however
many edges the SDP has so I'm not gonna
saying the person fire condition isn't
holding - all yeah it's mines me but I'm
not requiring you in this situation when
you get the expander which which
directions well what do you respond
there nothing matters because everything
is within constant so in that case I
mean it really bear with me I just named
it local by myself you know it's not I
just wanted a name for it and it's not
local in the sense of locality that you
might have in mind that just didn't know
how to name it basically I mean I have
all these crazy names in the paper that
it's just the only localities that you
only look at that subspace you project
everything onto that subspace and you
work as if you're laplacian was around k
matrix on that subspace
however the the other when the next
slide is more global and it actually
does not project onto anything it just
proves that there is a way around it I
also I mean I call those stars bar
sapphires and the reason being because
when we're working on it we had this
star on the board on the property we
wanted and we always would call it star
so I have a whole paper with a theorem
that says stars versification not
getting a whole paper but only with the
name of star so I didn't want to come up
like come and say okay we have the star
specification so I put local
specification yeah anyway so now I'm
gonna be talking about give me games and
how they Guinea games conjecture is
false and expanded constrained graphs
well I mean nobody comes extra did Forex
panic restrain graphs I'm just gonna
solve that teeny games is easy on
expander constraint graphs because solve
eating games but let's go back for a
step and say basically
is going on with np-hard problems so
np-hard problems are hard to solve but
the next best thing is approximation
algorithms so for example there are a
lot of important problems like click max
reset set cover that have almost optimal
they have an approximation algorithm set
and actually it's proved that basically
that's the best you can do up to some
lower their terms sometimes so this is
pretty much type using the PCP theorem
in the pilot or addition theorem and you
know there's not two months more to do
in approximation how are there these
other important problems like vertex
cover max cot much case ESP that there
this sometimes folklore sometimes STP
base sometimes I'm not sure how this
works is TP also algorithms that
actually then P hardness that has been
proved for them has a large gap like is
not matching the the approximation
algorithm T are those problem still open
that we're gonna see in a bit and there
are other problems like this process cut
that basically we have a squared log an
approximation I don't eat where V and no
hardness other than like no Peters
basically is no so this is still open so
let's see in approximability in the lens
of unique games conjecture so now we
wanted to have all these selves the
vertex cover in the mock Scott and marks
cases be problems and we wanted to find
a way to close the gap either way like
is better proximation algorithms are
better inapproximability lower bounds or
better I mean by some definition of
better so let's see the previous board
or table that we had there we have this
these gaps here and if you assume
something that's called the guinea gates
conjecture basically this gaps close and
I mean for the non-uniform version this
becomes better for the uniform version
there's nothing else known again unless
the original uni games graph has some
expansion that's just a motivation I
haven't defined the uni games haven't
find the graph so let's see what is
green games a special case of it with
today's this case to deal with linear
equations mod K so you're given a bunch
of constraints that have the form X I -
cases some it equals some value mod K
where K is the alphabet size it's a
prime and you're asked to find the
maximum number of constraints that can
be simultaneously satisfied so it's a
maximization problem and you can see it
as a constraint graph so you have you
know for its variable a big node and
then it's adds represents you know one
of these constraints between the
variables so that's the unique games
constraint graph the underlying graph
that I'm going to be talking about but
you could also say there's some mother
graph which is called the label extended
graph and it's variable now it's it's
its original variables replaced by three
little variables that correspond to the
labels here we have label size three and
it's you know its original edges
replaced by you know edges between the
corresponding label is that satisfying
the constraint the reason why it's
called unique games and not just games
is because this thing is a matching it's
a permutation so it's constrained just
is a one-to-one matching a yeah function
then that's called the label X in this
graph I would care so if I'm going to be
using this tool a lot so we need to
understand okay so we have like this
graph and that's clear why that's the
inner game or the game
okay the games comes from a different
motivation which is proved very fair
games I don't want to get into that but
forget the games yeah so this is just
the modeling of what I'm saying find the
maximum number of edges that can be
colored or satisfied but you can see as
you know here we have three labels white
silver and gray weiselberger so it's one
two three one two three and here we had
before the identity permutation so white
goes to white silver goes to silver grey
goes to gray so the way to satisfy that
original edge was to assign either white
white either silver silver or gray gray
that could be an assignment that would
satisfy that constraint so just a
different model of the unique am which
it's like a list when in in graph theory
these are pretty sure you know that
these are called lists but so in
particularly this list can be used as a
modeling of the in a game and basically
now the the nice thing about that is
that you know you can visualize the
labelings
by picking out you know with I mean if
you if you assign white white I don't
know white and white then this is not a
completely satisfying labeling and you
can see why from that picture what you
have to find in this new setting is a
little bit strange right
well you don't have to find anything so
far I'm just I'm using this as a tool to
find what I need to find but if you can
bear with me for a couple of slides you
might have a better understanding of why
I'm modeling it like that is the problem
that corresponds to satisfy the maximum
numbers constraint original sure I'm
gonna be talking about that a lot like
so just if you still have questions
after that please let me know okay so in
particular as I said before the you know
these three edges are satisfied here and
this is not and the optimum way of the
game is 3 over 4 I mean that's just a
picture of how you can relate satisfying
assignment stuff ok so that are unique
games and what is the conjecture
basically it says that this unique game
problem is hard to approximate and it's
due to cop 2002 right in other words it
says that for lies are for the sizes and
be hard to tell that if the game is 99%
satisfied were 1% satisfiable well
that's great because as we saw before it
leads to all these tightness in
approximation inapproximability results
so however nobody you know could say
boys juries it falls what's going on
what's a notorious open problem but
nobody knows what to do they have been
approximation algorithms offer unique
games and these are some of them and now
that you see all the the first 5 depends
on N or the alphabet size sorry that
should have been K I had it pay for a
prime but this is cake so either depend
on K or RN so isentropically it could be
really bad and what we proved in that
paper which is joint work with our to
see any card star and Vishnoi and it's a
merge of two papers basically to have so
many people we basically have an
algorithm that does not depend ok or n
it depends on expansion
and they basically finds the 99%
satisfying assignment if the game is 1
minus epsilon satisfiable and the graph
is a spectral family so you know we
would have a different kind of
dependency here with the rest which
works very well some expanders and
that's what I'm gonna be talking about
in the rest of the table but let's let's
sit back and say you know why one would
even look at expanders you know why
would you know not look at planar graphs
I don't know something else well there
is um this expansion and sparse it's got
things I've been talking about and also
our previous table that said that sparse
is Scott is a very weird problem nobody
knows how to prove inapproximability
results for that so there is unlikely
even assuming any games that there is a
reduction from uni games to sparser
Scott not not true just unlikely the
reason being that if you start with the
guinea games instance that does have a
sparse cut then the old non redactions
are long called reductions say that have
been used in approximability they're
gonna create a sparse cut instance that
also has a sparse cap and that does not
is not going to depend of whether or not
beginning game systems is a yes or no
instance to begin with so there's no
like away with these current techniques
that we have to do this to to create you
know such a good reduction unless the
game again has some expansion which also
was observed by Carlton wish- my
co-authors in the manuscript so there is
actually a reduction from an expanding
in the game systems to sparse iske and
the reason being that that situation
here cannot happen if the graph is
expanding so the only good you know cuts
in the sparse is cut instance could
correspond somehow to good labelings
so there was this off-the-record belief
that expanding graphs where indeed may
be not the hardest instances but hard
instances so there was this belief going
on when I was talking to people while I
was working on that problem they were
surprised that I thought it was easy and
expand research so that's the picture
and now what we saw basically as I said
before that when the game
Union game is a yes instance at 1-7
unsatisfiable instance then and the
algebra connectivity of the graph is
large then we have a good algorithm that
recovers a 99% satisfying assignment
focused about that title because if you
see the integer is false in some case we
mean in particular it's false okay so I
I explained before you so I should have
saved that you're right but I said that
it's not false on expert yeah okay so
why let's say because before I said lot
expanders where we live to be hard what
happened so far well for intuition let's
look at the perfectly satisfiable game
in a perfectly sensible game it's easy
to determine like it's easy to determine
if I can be game instance is a hundred
percent satisfiable and let's look at
that weird graph and pretend that this
was an expander because it's not but
pretend that this is an expander as we
observe this is a perfectly satisfiable
game here you can pick gray white white
and silver/gray silver you know any way
you can pick it has exactly three
perfect labor links and if the graph was
an expander a cut that corresponds to
there is no graph would cut a lot of
edges because it would correspond to the
expander cut which would be large and in
particular the only good cuts that cut
exactly zero edges are those if you pick
out the correct labels for its note so
that's why this is a nice picture of the
unique game because you can see in that
cut sense so you see that if you pick
out the satisfying labeling put it in
one side and the rest in the other side
you can zero edges so this instance of
linear equations have actually three are
perfect as fine assignments and it's
disconnected it's three copies of the
graph disconnected okay so that's that's
a very nice picture but we already know
that perfectly sensible games are easy
to determine well and one one except on
game is an almost perfectly satisfiable
one so I'm gonna I'm gonna talk about
what that means but intuitively one
would expect that now we're in good
shape we could do something about it
okay but then
I was talking about all of these teepees
and eigenvalues and you know sparse cots
are hard to determine so even you know I
just said sparse this card is an np-hard
problem what do we do like how could you
find a card that corresponds to a good
labeling or something is no way well
let's go back to my max cut slide which
probably should or shouldn't have been
there but we'll see and let's look at
what now we can do so remember a max cut
I showed you a reduction I mean not a
reduction in duality between stp value
and eigen value and what happens to me
in the games well it is a combinatorial
termination problem it can be cast as an
STP and in particular what happens if
you look at the dual well let's see what
happens if we look at the dual it turns
out that we can have an eigenvalue bomb
so don't dwell solution your objective
is bounded by some lambda two but what
is that lambda two well remember the
label extended grafted before you were
asking me where it's a lambda two that
graph so the identity matrix of that
graph is just the original distance
matrix replaced and its entry that was
one would correspond to an edge it's
replaced by the permutation that's
sitting on that edge so now we have a
great tool we have a steep ado ality
gives you a lambda to bound of that nice
matrix yeah which is the matrix of the
label extended graph so now let's go
back to the previous slide and we will
look at the game again so we had all
these cards that correspond to expander
that were big the other cuts were good
that correspond to labor links how do we
relate cards with spectra the only AG in
values of the the the matrix M that I
was saying before there just make sure
the label X in that graph that are large
are the ones that correspond again to
perfectly Billings and all the other
eigenvalues for expanders are comparable
to the lambda 2 of the original
constraint graph for the expansion so
basically this lambda 2 as well as the
rest that correspond to assignments are
large for expanders only if and only if
the game is satisfiable and for however
many satisfied
it has so now we're in good shape we
have a tool and let's do some reverse
engineering because I promised before
that we looked at perfect games and then
something magic happens and we have one
minus Epsilon games well let's start
with a one minus Epsilon game this ads
here is a problematic ads it's not
satisfiable but we can but we can think
of it as coming from a perfect game that
some bad adversary chosen ads or
absolute fraction of the edges and you
know adversary we preserve those edges
to make them bad so that's now my
original game that was a perturbation of
the other game or vice versa we look
again at that matrix that I talked about
before and we observed that as I said
before there are as many large
eigenvector eigenvalue Sirte correspond
to large eigenvalues as many as
satisfying assignments and these are
actually a basis for those the
characteristic vectors of the labeling
of the assignments so one its blog has a
one unit and the zeros are there was one
corresponding to the flag that lights
out for white gray or silver and that's
like the eigenspace well yeah that's
supposed to be there in space and for
expanders what we proved in the paper
that uh lie there in Vegas have really
small eigenvalue and now let's see what
that means look again at the 1 minus
epsilon game we you know that that game
can be seen us now in a matrix sense as
a excellent perturbation of that matrix
that was here but now it's not anymore
which should have been so you know it's
enough some perturbation of the matrix
and it's an excellent perturbation of
that eigen space well that doesn't say
anything only that the the fact that you
proof for expanders implies that the
interpreter says their assignment eigen
space has a large gap from the rest so
there is label K K dimension of Lars
good eigen space and k plus 1 and more
they're just really bad eigenvalues so
there is a big spectral gap and
perturbation of matrices tells us that
when that happens this perturbation does
not change things by Matt in the
spectral sense so eigen vectors in the
right hand side space are close to eigen
vectors in the left hand side space and
in particular what does that mean well
it means that for every vector here you
can find the vector here that are
closing l2 norm and remember what where
the vectors here though these vectors
were satisfying assignments this vectors
were characteristic vectors of
satisfying assignments so in particular
you could somehow with one more extra
step find those vectors and let's see
what's the extra step so we have a
labeling algorithm
compute the first square I can vectors
have a pre third game i discretize the
span so basically after that since you
know case a bottle again in the
application that we're looking at this
hospital normal in many number of points
and basically as i said before there is
a vector in this epsilon net that is
close to an assignment vector and what
does closed mean well it basically means
that this vector here is going to have
most blocks with a single big entry and
here are some blocks really bad but this
blocks with a single big entry would be
the big entry that corresponds to the
correct labeling so we just have that
vector to us and there you go that's the
99% satisfying assignment so in
particular I want to say one more thing
because we have two proofs of that
theorem I mean the previous proof works
for linear equations mod P this works
for general case there's a yet another
connection with respect to an SDP which
can be greatly demonstrated in that
proof which I'm not going to talk about
and it's in the paper if you yeah yeah
anyway so basically now in the other
proof what it does it's again yet
another another novel rounding of the
SDP solution for the Uni games the SDP
that I showed you before and you
basically you know have a vector
solution and from for uni games and you
create a vector solution for the sparse
Escada SDP without triangle inequalities
and if the expansion is big constant
note that basically
if you have local correlations between
ads that means that STP value aligns
vectors for edges then it somehow would
mean that it aligns globally vectors
because you know in expanders however
much you walk in edges you walk in a
random pair of vertices which I made
like another half hard to explain that's
where I'm not gonna explain okay
so that's basically the end of the
unique games part of my talk and if you
want to ask any questions
you should know okay this is just one
slide about a couple of other things
that I have done one of them is with Lee
and we have a construction of
integrality gaffers process cut universe
process card that matches collisional
hardness and gives some intuition and
probably some way around proving tighter
bounds which I'm gonna probably send to
CCC and this we have I don't know for
those of you who know I steep in
hierarchies we're looking at lesser
hierarchy for a while turns out it's
harder than we hoped it would be but we
do have a one additional round gap we
developed a whole new technique quickly
to get a one additional round out for
vertex cover to my reception that's with
Satyam Callen we're sending a lot of CCC
as well exposed and now if you don't
have any more questions I'd like to talk
about what I want to work in the future
and what I've been working on so I've
already been thinking about some very
exciting problems that relate to my work
mostly and I want to share them with you
so one of them is resolved the innoGames
context you're using spectral techniques
because we know that sPB's fail
we have bounced code Vishnoi showed STP
cannot do more than that
and I wonder like since there is another
way around it can we use that to solve
unique games and graphs at STP fails
nobody knows I've worked on it with
people in specs will graph theory with
Joel Friedman and expert and expanders
and stuff that we couldn't Friday I
thought I saw Jenny Gamez but then I
realized that happened so that was
disappointing then you know you know
first part subscribe as I said before I
really want really want to work on that
problem warp and you know see if I can
use the techniques we developed in that
paper with Lee and you know close the
gap basically I believe there is a lower
bound of squared login that matches the
RV and you know maybe we're gonna have
to use like heavier pre-analysis we're
thing about entropy conjecture and stuff
like that in the past but we still don't
know how to put all these things
together and you know investigate the
power of this notorious SDP hierarchies
with basically very very few lower
bounds are known and very very few girls
are known so either way I'm gonna be
very happy to say well this strong
powerful seeming listy please can give
you better algorithms or not those are
some things I've been thinking about and
then some exciting problems I plan to
think about with send enough time yet so
that came as a natural consequence of
our work and sparsa fires and the
question is the following
give me a graph and describe it with the
effective resistance map for those of
you who don't know I can explain
one-to-one so but I can describe with
the effective resistance map is that
enough to specify the whole spectrum is
that like a one-to-one function thing or
what is the property of the graph that
can be revealed by that map then I'm
interested in random behavior like
random graphs behavior or nasty piece in
hierarchies and not hierarchies and
whatever else has I've been looking on
the clique problem for lesser it turns
out it's much harder than we thought so
as well I mean we have some
half-finished work in that but I don't
think I even want to you know start
digging into that right now and then
something that
you've all suggested in the past which I
have been you know telling myself to
work on but then I've been busy with all
these other stuff the ternary what the
recursive minds already function and
using techniques from additive
combinatorics salat alfu to you know to
get an intuition for random matrices
basically like little boudoir for
problems and stuff like that i tried to
work on that in couple of years back but
turns out that these two people are
better than me that's a joke but yeah I
would like to explore technocratic
combinatorics in random matrices and see
what intuition can I get from that
complicated in fact the more liquor